qui dans notre paysage politique depuis
des décennies a amené des plus grands
combats en matière de handicap la droite
républicaine et jacques chirac en
particulier qui a mené les plus grands
combats pour protéger les femmes depuis
simone veil et tant d'autres lois qui
ont été portées par la droite
républicaine qui a veillé à ce que le
travail paye vraiment ce qui est une
véritable justice sociale c'est la
droite républicaine et votre question
est importante parce qu'il est probable
que depuis quelques années font je crois
depuis le deuxième quinquennat de la
deuxième campagne électorale pardon de
nicolas sarkozy on est perdus de vue que
l'adn de la droite républicaine c'était
d'installer de la justice dans notre
pays oui mais concrètement qu'est ce que
ça veut dire exemple concret au nom un
exemple concret durant 5 ans avec
d'autres de mes collègues j'ai bataillé
pour des conjugue alizés l'allocation
adulte handicapé voilà un sujet qui
n'est pas un petit sujet qui est un
sujet qui dit beaucoup des injustices de
notre pays ceux qui nous écoutent le
savent peut-être pas on a aujourd'hui
dans notre pays une allocation adulte
handicapé qui est conditionné au revenu
du conjoint c'est une injustice profonde
et pas un détail technique sommes battus
pendant cinq ans sur ce sujet je me suis
moi même battu sur ce sujet qui a refusé
de corriger cette injustice emmanuel
macron et son gouvernement et bien voilà
un sujet qui n'est pas un détail ce
détail là il dit une différence de
vision de la société entre nous la
droite rien demandé à le faire la
maternité va d'ailleurs c'était un point
d'accord avec marine le pen s'était
surtout pardon mais à l'assemblée
nationale ce combat la marine le pen
elle n'était pas là lorsqu'on l'a mené à
il ya un an car les deux étaient allés
cette injustice peut-être mais moi je
juge au fait ya ceux qui parlent
beaucoup et puis ya ceux qui font et je
vous redis que ce sujet là est pour moi
la démonstration de deux visions de la
société et je considère que la vision de
la société que j'aie n'est pas la même
que celle d' emmanuel macron ce qui
était mon droit le plus strict mais
alors quelle est la marque distinctive
dallaire d'en haut la lutte contre les
injustices j'ai bien compris mais tous
s'en réclament donc elle est le petit
plus de l air dans tout cela défendre
les français mais depuis cinq ans où
tout le monde sait ça aussi peut-être
mais moi je vais le dire différemment
depuis cinq ans qui concrètement au delà
de le dire l'a fait depuis cinq ans qui
sont les députés l'assemblée nationale
qui ont vraiment défendu les français je
vous citer des exemples à l'erreur s'ils
de dire vous avez le monopole de la
défense des france anne hommel de tous
les martyrs pas le monopole est sûrement
n'aurait pas cette modestie en revanche
depuis cinq ans sur tous les sujets que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure sur la
question de la défense des salaires sur
la question du handicap sur la question
des violences conjugales sur la question
de la ligue ça a été la candidate a
semblé les allées du pouvoir d'achat à
l'assemblée où je vous parle depuis les
yeux ce matin je vous parle les
anciennes quant à l'assemblée nationale
je reviens un peu plus loin depuis cinq
ans ces combats nous les avons mené est
ce que les députés du rassemblement
national les ont menées non pas du tout
pardonnez moi mais ils n'étaient même
pas présents dans l'hémicycle ce qu'ils
aiment pas un détail stocks présents sur
le plateau de ce que la majorité l'a
noté les fallas en carrosse yves aux
normes principal la majorité blême la
majorité de ne pas mener non la majorité
de la permanet les exemples que j'ai
cités tout à l'heure ils sont à
l'initiative des députés les
républicains est ce que les députés les
insoumis ont mené cette bataille là non
ces batailles ils les battent à la
bataille des députés insoumis a été n 2
russe met en scène un sou mais leur
bazar
président